mike duffy
says
for an ama can you do a quick overview
of your podcast setup and what equipment
you use if you want what i can do mike
is and if anyone else is interested i
can do a
like i mentioned i i'm i can do a
separate video of simply what it takes
to prepare for a tow podcast and go over
my setup there
fanny ram says how many hours a day does
curt get to study how many hours for a
workout so i used to work about
12 hours a day or so now i can do it for
about four or five hours though
yesterday i i did maybe 14 or 15 hours
so it varies but on average it's about
four or five now
given recent events
and working out is about 20 minutes to
30 minutes a day on average
fanny also asks kurt seems so well
studied thank you before an interview
sometimes without sleep that's true
how come he doesn't get divorced
so it's because i prioritize time with
my wife fanny it's what keeps me sane
it's also what makes life worth it for
myself i used to think that all that
matters is work
and i remember planning out a route to
be a billionaire
now
i don't even care about being a
millionaire
outside of the financial security that
owning a million or two provides clearly
such as being able to afford a home here
in toronto right now i'm a rent i'm
renting and pay for whatever my family
needs such as an emergency or to send my
parents on a vacation
or buy
my in-laws a car
in terms of bills and so on
almost all i care about now is being a
good husband
and
that's that's been something that i've
come to the conclusion of over the past
couple months
it's
the
feeling that
all will fade in some manner
and that whatever prideful importance i
think i have firstly is
it's far less than i imagine and
secondly it's
even if it's the same as my inflated ego
wants to believe then
this is only a fleeting moment
if anything is worth
anything it has to stand the test of
something akin to time i don't see time
because i don't believe that
looking at some temporal duration is
what matters
but
it's something akin to time
and that there's an integral
connection between doing what's
temporary and what's sinful i'm using
plenty of
religious language i
i understand i i see and
if you like you can
convert it to whatever secular
version
or synonym you would like to if
you find that you're unable to conceive
of yourself as anything other than a
rational being
so then
if
whatever this is is only a moment
relatively speaking then it would be
worth every
little bit if it's with my wife and if
she feels adored and if i feel the same
and that's priceless there's there's an
infinite quality to that an infinite
quality to that
whatever else i
i do may be misrepresented and taken
from me diana pasulka
and i discussed this that
people take the nirvana logo kids do and
they have no idea what nirvana music
sounds like or
the good fortune in san cri sanskrit
becomes the nazi symbol so it's it's as
if what you do escapes you after you've
done it additionally
whatever one does
will get critiqued by those who are
seeking status
i know i do this frequently i'm
extremely
jealous
and
we all are
i see it in myself thirdly it will be
forgotten in
decades or centuries
it's rare that it would last longer than
that so what will be worth it in the end
now in the end again i'm using time
there and i don't mean to it's just i
don't know if we have the the language i
think that it's all worth it
in the end
if it's about harmony and forgiveness
and
and mercy and love and
generosity and i can feel that most with
my wife
i feel it and i practice it and the more
that i'm able to do it with
with her the more i'm able to do that
broadly with others and feel it from
others
and even extend that to
say homeless people on the streets who i
never used to donate to
but now i have this
intimation that the quality of a society
is how we treat
the homeless people
in our society and i mean that at a
personal level not a governmental level
because as soon as you say well the
government should take care of it i
think they should
but that doesn't mean that you don't or
i don't have more way way more than
enough
to donate and help them
and speak to them like they're
they're people that aren't just the
receivers of
your
almostenary nature so that you can feel
like you're doing something good when
it's
it's to
scratch that charitable urge
and it's
it's not coming from the right place and
you speak or at least i
would have
if i'm donating i would stand and give
them the money i think it's better to to
sit at their level their level even that
has a patronizing bend to it
but regardless to feel that
kindness
with my wife from my wife to my wife
it also helps me
retroactively change
the past and that's extremely
interesting because we talked about time
so how does that work i think about the
times that i've been hurt and there are
plenty of times and i
mainly think about the times that i've
been hurt
in relationships and so on and i'm able
to recontextualize them as positive
experiences now carl pilkington once
said that you don't know if you enjoyed
a vacation until years later because you
look back and you say well when i was
swinging on that swing set it started to
rain and i had to duck for cover and i
hated it at the time but i look back on
it fondly and i realized quote unquote
that i indeed enjoyed it it was fun
ricky gervais then interrupted and said
no no you didn't have fun
you look back and think it's fun but
that's not the same thing
and i remember agreeing with ricky i no
longer
i i don't know if i do any
anymore i don't know if it's the case
that however you felt in the past is
stamped down
and it's fixed i think that there's
something about recontextualizing
one's emotions about an event that
somehow actually changed the event
and well it's it's strange to think like
that because then you have to have as a
different basis something different than
materialism or physicalism
you have to somehow take the emotions as
primary and there are philosophical
strains that do so for example
phenomenology i don't know if if the
experience of the initial emotion has
some canonical status over one's
experience now projecting onto the past
it's not clear to me at all it's
intuitively not clear and i think we all
feel this because we've had moments like
this but just because we feel it doesn't
mean it's true but doesn't mean it's not
true i'm still thinking about it so this
means that going back to the original
statement of me finding primary being a
good
husband
or a good son or good son of the good or
a good son of the universe or what
whatever this means
that somehow this has to do with being
kind
and
merciful
and munificent
and
concerned and warm-hearted
it makes it not only worth it in the end
but it makes it worth it certainly in
the present but perhaps even in the past
which means it makes it eternally worth
it wittgenstein had a quote about this
by the way he said that if
if we were to take eternity not to mean
infinite temporal duration but
timelessness then an eternal life
belongs or belong to those who live in
the
present
i think he may be correct though it
takes an extreme amount of courage to
live in the present at least for myself
it's not it's it's no trivially just no
trifling trivial matter
it's
extremely formidable
i think he's correct though i don't i
think that the mechanism may apply to
the future into the past as well
okay joseph pts wants to know would you
consider having eric back on to
specifically discuss the physics of
geometric unity
yes when i have the time to make a video
about how to go through a physics paper
that one currently doesn't understand so
i referenced that in the crash course on
physics
and
i would like to tell you all about the
schedule but i i don't have much
time left here this has already taken so
much more than i thought i'm only about
a quarter of the way done i thought it'd
be half done or more the point of the
toe podcast is for it to lead somewhere
it's not simply interviewing people for
the sake of speaking to people that i'm
interested in
like rogan or lex or a russell brand
though they're great great great
podcasts
and
i'm i'm not diminishing them in the
least that's just not what toe is toe is
toe has a goal there's a trajectory
that's trying to be hit with virtually
every episode it's about explicating
toes and learning them deeply